sup fellas what you guys up to I know
they just watching the news a 6.5
earthquake rocked the Chilean coast
today leaving nine people dead and 54
injured President Obama has pledged
relief efforts as thousands are without
food and shelter and local news a
drive-by shooting in East Los Angeles
last night has left two innocent
bystanders hospitalized one of the
victims a 15 year old girl is paralyzed
from the waist down while her mother is
on life support and has a 15% chance of
surviving the night in some good news it
looks like Daniel Hume who is believed
to have died several years ago in a
plane crash has been found alive on a
remote island earlier today mr. Hume was
reunited with his young daughter Kate
who hadn't seen since she was a baby mr.
Hume survived on the island for years by
killing indigenous animals and drinking
water that condensed on plants in the
morning friends and family are grateful
to have him back and we wish him all the
best
Oh God Star Wars trailers on Star Wars
trailers on
no one be b8 I was raised to do one
thing I've got nothing to fight for
Oh son nothing will stand in our way
finish
when he started
damn that kylo Ren scare
there are stories about what happened
Oh
with that look at that look look at that
Oh
Poe Dameron I will be your wingman yes
yes that's what Star Wars is that's what
Star Wars it you believe that light
saber force there's to it yeah
whoa that's Star Wars
breaking news aliens have landed on
earth little is known about these
creatures but they were spotted landing
their phallic like spaceship in a
7-eleven parking lot President Obama has
sent a special envoy including Gary
Busey Kanye West and ELISA Queen to
greet or extraterrestrial friends more
on that story as it develops
and these prequels are awesome there's a
train there's a train have you felt it
in local news a drive-by shooting left
two innocent bystanders hospitalized in
East Los Angeles last night a 15 year
old girl is paralyzed from the waist
down and her mother 45 is on life
support it has a 15 percent chance of
living through the night
your monsters your monsters and I'm
coming after you all of our best from
the news that was so awesome man
what you want to do now lightsaber
battle lightsaber battle
whoo Jedi
you okay you really hurt
yeah I gotta go so good luck with that
you
you